the world's number one women's player
that is ash barty she announced her
retirement overnight she guys is only
25 years old and she is at the top of
her game the australian broke the news
yesterday on instagram in an emotional
interview with her former doubles
partner casey del aqua barty says she
started thinking of hanging up her
racket for good after winning wimbledon
last year which was a lifelong dream she
says the real tipping point was winning
this year's australian open barty is the
first australian champion in nearly half
a century listen
i think that for me just feels like the
most perfect way
my perfect way to
to celebrate what an amazing journey my
tennis career has been as a person this
is this is what i want um this is i
wanna i wanna chase after some other
dreams that i've always wanted to do and
wow
i so admire me too
i love it the idea that she says i wanna
chase after other dreams she said ash
barty the person has so many dreams that
she wants to chase after that don't
necessarily involve traveling the world
being away from my family being away
from my home which is where i've always
wanted to be i can't wait to see what
those dreams are but you need to say it
25 to no with such convictions there's a
certain
guilt that athletes have when they walk
away too soon from the game because they
feel like they have to stay in the game
because they are living somebody else's
dream we hear all the time that's fast
oh man it must be amazing you know what
i would do to play in the nfl you know
what i'll do to be a tennis player i
would give my left arm right at that
level at that level and you think to
yourself i can't walk away i've been
blessed with these gifts i have to play
this game she's saying you know what i
don't want to live somebody else's dream
already lived this dream it was amazing
they had a great run but how many
athletes do you see that retire at the
top of their game isn't that rare it is
rare it is but i do believe it's going
to happen more often than one they're
making a lot more money okay so they can
walk away but we have to keep this in
mind as well
she didn't just luck into being the best
tennis player in the world is the best
she is and she worked her butt off since
she was a kid and she's probably
fatigued and tired she's like you know
what i want to chase something else i
think you're right i think that this is
just where we are today especially after
this pandemic where now young people are
leading the way and saying i don't have
to do the one thing that i was meant to
do for my entire life i can do other
things i call that the new rich that's
right ash barty you go